في سياق اخر اكدت موسكو وبيجين متانه
العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه وتطورها رغم
الاضطرابات الدوليه وقال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين خلال استقباله رئيس مكتب
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في اللجنه المركزيه
للحزب الشيوعي الصيني
قال ان العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه تتطور
بشكل تدريجي وتصل الى افاق جديده بينما
قال المسؤول الصيني انه يقف الى جانب
تعدديه الاقطاب ان بلاده مع مستعده لتعزيز
الاتصالات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه مع
روسيا
العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه تتطور وفقا لما
خططنا له خلال السنوات الماضيه كل شيء
يتطور تدريجيا وقد وصلنا الى افاق جديده
الحديث يدور عن التعاون في المجال
الاقتصادي وضعنا لانفسنا هدف بلوغ حجم
التبادل التجاري بين بلدينا الى 200 مليار
دولار بحلول الفين واربعه وعشرين في العام
الماضي بلغ حجم التبادل التجاري بين
بلدينا 185 مليار دولار وهناك كل الاسباب
للاعتقاد باننا سنحقق اهدافنا في هذا
المجال روسيا على علم بالاحداث السياسيه
الداخليه المهمه التي جرت في الصين والتي
ستساهم في تعزيز البلاد وتهيئه الظروف
لتطويرها وفقا لمخططات الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني